what happens when 800 of the world's
most elite footballers and their
managers live together under one roof
players stop being polite and start
getting real this is the champion people
say I lack focus I say focus on dis
rules are meant to be broken
so is masala I'm not here to make
friends I'm here to make history
I'm not here to make friends either but
if I did make a friend and that'd be
nice because I'm a bit lonely a trio at
first I thought it was a language
barrier thing but now speaks in Spanish
and still nobody I've been with barsa
most of my life it's more than a
football club it's really more like a
family since Donald Ressler
it's important that I step up as the
emotional leader of a satine kryze is
afraid we'll have to play La Liga match
in America it's my job to make sure that
all the players on the team are happy
like I've noticed Messi has been a bit
down since the World Cup
[Music]
I think he realizes he'll never win a
World Cup with Argentina so I thought it
would be fun to take Messi and the rest
squad to a pottery class if he can't win
a World Cup he can make one so I'm
making a Latin Grammy for Mia mourn
Shakira she collects them when are you
going to give it to it whenever we're
what are you making Malcolm I'm making
rocket ooch
oh wow like this is uncanny guys you
guys look see how happy he is Leo hold
up your World Cup so I can take a
picture of you with it
no PK it's not for me it's for Cristiano
of course he's not sad about Argentina
he said because he misses Ronaldo in La
Liga without the Joker
there's no Batman without Fraser there's
no Ally without Russian sports there's
no anti-doping agency these things need
each other I'm very excited to give her
North on my gift
[Music]
dear Christiano we had so many epic
classical's together but this will
always be how I remember you
[Music]
[Music]